quand vous mangez et c'est moi qui lave
vaisselle après accord au nahd moines
wekiss à sa bombe à 0 patrice pour
n'arriver de chantier mais par son team
et encore qu'on met tout le talent on
n'a pas cela
ah bon l'un vitaly ont dit à moi d'en
inviter à tant rêver tout le monde
d'accord vous dit pas mot rien en cas
d'accord mais pas mal un petit puzzle et
chérie ok bien dit qu'on fait après ses
bons parks à six mois et les années à me
donner beaucoup métro qui a la vision
qu'ils sachent qu'on sait du colo mon
enfance à gazon sont sur l'examen msha
mois nouveau le tour pour coiffer non
mais s'acheter un nouveau le tome sauver
un système de la fausse agression
etienne a fait est importante alors
c'est quoi
mais ça fait l'examen comme ça du coup
n'ont pas tous les concerts partout sa
mort en soirée la roma ça comme ça de la
libye un siège unis non non non non pas
comme ouveillan internet
enfin ni en terreur ou comment une
brouille là-haut comme comme on veut
qu'aux non mais bon début noté marié
plus vient à plusieurs médias mme
isabelle vialle on s'appelait dépistage
du cancer du côlon un dépistage du
cancer du côlon collomb oui collomb
colons 1848 esclavage on retourne là-bas
au moins au passage a fait bonne cause
je souhaitais c'est quoi le colon connu
parce que le colon m'explique quand même
attendre c'est quoi soudain comme un
stylo un papier ou whitman un crayon et
riza paiement vers 10 heures
ça la regarde sa maîtresse un oui là ça
c'est quoi ça c'est l'estomac ça
d'accord
apprenez le petit intestin ok ok ensuite
juste après le titre destin ou 1 à
l'aube aux intestins d'accord balogou
intestat dieylani d'un roi avec la peine
la troc et qui voit la voile en amérique
tome nous vois ça la sas et ça c'est le
colon ça c'est ça le goulot oui c'est ça
le goulot et me voient parfois on peut
avoir un bon petit polypes dessus des
petits quoi au lit bougeait comme espèce
de champignon va ok alors yalla yalla
c'est ça qui devient con c'est le
comment mais en fait aux fugues au fil
du temps voie libre en disant vous dire
que c est le truc c'est que il faut me
des pistes ali et comme on me fait ça
mais c'est grâce vois ça c'est le cas ça
c'est quoi le cacao ok d'accord ne
connais pas si elle à la ligue pro tools
avec le vaudeville police et linkedin a
dû sortir quand le cac ait eu du bon
attaquant et qu'on fait la leçon et dans
le sang c'est là qu'on peut détecter sur
l'ena bonne polypes ou pas qui pouvait
devenir conseiller comme en connaissant
avait un dépistage dont il envoya au
elle être une fille des pistons ok
d'accord ça voir de médecin traitant ou
un lit donna aux espèces de type boîte
noire et iwate le dans la bonne case et
oman bonne trucs dedans le monde se
calme un truc un truc voie d'accord et
buonocore ou comme peut pas voir si dans
le sens où envoyant des pistes un
dépistage ya au cinéma ou pas et cinéma
le sang pendant que sa volée outre
attali ou voit on traite le bolide
encore comme ça qu'on l'a titré tout
bonne polypes là où koné ou les troncs
qui connait un polype et pour 10 ans 20
ans a surtout franchement jamais je
n'aurais pensé était facile règle le
problème quand c'est raté mais
franchement milles du duo merkozy
m'arrêter
quoi comment la droite unie de service à
temps
non
maman est ce que cela finit geyson
invitation z
cela peut encore des rescapés dans cette
boîte aux lettres bientôt sotigui ça
bonjour docteur deux juges ça va bien
très bien ça va merci est ce que
bouteflika nous runes dépistage ses
coûts et à l'orane dépistage c'est une
association qui est financé par le
ministère de la santé la sécurité
sociale et qui a pour but de valoriser
le dépistage organisé est de faire
reculer le cancer quel cancer en
particulier alors trois cancers on a
commencé par les cancers du sein
s'appelait avant mamou ron ensuite le
cancer du côlon et le cancer plus
récemment du col de l'utérus et beaucoup
et rien que ces trois conseillers là
parce que c'est les cancers qui évolue
lentement et c'est des cancers qui sont
fréquents 1 le cancer du côlon est
fréquent chez l'homme et la femme
surtout à partir de 50 ans les cancers
du sein celle du cancer le plus fréquent
chez la femme et cancer du col de
l'utérus est un cancer qui
malheureusement est encore fréquent sur
leader in et faire un dépistage et la
croyance et end alors sa soeur à
dépister des visions un stade précoce
qui sont peut-être même pas encore
cancéreuses pré cancéreuse et qui vont
permettre un traitement plus efficace et
moins lourd donc là de menus reçoit un
courriel à la casse c'est quoi cette
lettre alors grâce au fichier de
sécurité social on peut envoyer aux
personnes concernées
une invitation à se faire dépister donc
nous reçoit le croyez nous prend rendez
vous c'est quoi les différentes étapes
alors par exemple pour le cancer du sein
on va recevoir l'invitation avec la
liste les radiologues qui sont agréés on
va prendre rendez vous chez le
radiologue le radiologue va examiner la
personne n'a examiné les seins il va
faire une mammographie et cette
mammographie saine et normale sera
envoyé à un dépistage elle sera lue par
un deuxième radiologue
ils servent à quelque chose de faire
relire sa part une assise sur des
chiffres on trouve à peu près une 120
cancer par an grâce au dépistage d'une
organiser et à peu près neuf cancers
sont trouvés par la deuxième lecture
ah oui quand même et pour le cancer du
col de l'utérus commencé talent un
cancer du col de l'utérus on invite les
femmes à réaliser un frottis tous les 3
ans les femmes de 25 à 65 ans et pour
les cancers du côlon et pour le cancer
du côlon
invitation propose aux personnes d'aller
voir mon médecin traitant qui va nous
juger s'il est nécessaire ou non de
faire un dépistage et remettent un test
hémoccult à faire à la maison alors
maintenir le dialogue que les dépistages
les gratuits apparemment les fascine et
il est plus que nécessaire
en plus il peut rapporter gros ce qui
sauve des vies quand même un concert que
les prix à temps il peut être guéri
et puis c'est un acte d'amour vous êtes
bonne preuve de famille qu ensemble lève
l'état vous je me dis rien à fait
accepte l'invitation